merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre la question porte sur le format
du nouveau baccalauréat prévues pour
2021 et la place du sport dans ce
nouveau format
d'après les informations disponibles
éducation physique et sportive pourra
toujours faire l'objet d'une option
choisie en plus des deux heures
hebdomadaires prévues dans les
programmes dans un entretien paru le 30
septembre dernier dans le jdd vous avez
indiqué que le latin et le grec seront
les deux seules options qui rapporteront
des points bonus dans le nouveau
baccalauréat
cette annonce est conforme à la mac est
disponible en ligne qui annonce que
l'option langue et culture de
l'antiquité est évalué en contrôle
continu et donne lieu le cas échéant à
un bonus cette mesure n'est donc pas
prévu pour les options lv3 les arts et
donc l'éducation physique je ne souhaite
pas ici opposé des disciplines entre
elles cependant jusqu'à aujourd'hui les
langues vivantes étrangères les arts et
le sport était dé manière optionnelle
permet tant elle aussi d'obtenir des
points bonus pour le baccalauréat au
même titre que le latin et le grec alors
que la france accueillera dans les six
ans dans six ans les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
alors que le gouvernement a l'ambition
de renforcer la pratique sportive
alors que le même gouvernement souhaite
avoir trois millions de pratiquants
sportifs supplémentaires alors que
l'éducation a mis en place un programme
d'appui aux jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 avec une
labellisation génération 2024 alors que
dans le même temps l'olympiade
culturelle permettra de renforcer
l'accès à la culture pour l'ensemble des
français
il est surprenant que ni le sport ni les
arts ne puisse rapporter des points dans
le nouveau baccalauréat
quand le latin le grec bénéficieront
d'un coefficient 3 alors monsieur le
ministre
quelles sont les raisons de la
suppression de l'option sport mais
également des arts au baccalauréat à
partir de 2021 l'art et l'art parole est
à monsieur jean michel blanquer ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse madame la présidente messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
michel savin une question très
importante aussi
et il faudrait surtout pas opposer les
langues anciennes au l'éducation
physique et sportive d'autant plus que
vous avez fait référence aux jeux
olympiques est con on voit bien
évidemment dr des racines comme
le ministère l'éducation nationale vous
le savez accorde une attention toute
particulière au développement de
l'éducation physique et sportive est
essentielle à l'acquisition par les
jeunes de bons réflexes en matière
d'actifs izik vite et physique de
bien-être et de respect d'autrui la
réforme du lycée et du baccalauréat
général et technologique garantie pour
chaque élève un enseignement commun
obligatoire de deux heures en éducation
physique et sportive de la seconde à la
terminale et propose en outre un
enseignement optionnel de trois heures
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus et
beaucoup mieux que pour les langues
anciennes
le ps est ainsi la seule discipline à
être ouverte selon les mêmes modalités
à la fois en enseignements communs et
optionnelles à tous les élèves du lycée
général et technologique l'enseignement
optionnel de ps permet à tous les élèves
du lycée général et technologique
quels que soient leur projet
d'orientation d'approfondir leur
pratique sportive dans un objectif de
formation ou de santé par ailleurs le
dispositif des sections sportives
scolaires maintenu dans le cadre de la
réforme permet la valorisation dans la
scolarité d'un haut niveau de pratique
sportive
la réforme du lycée et du baccalauréat
implique également une évolution des
programmes et le conseil supérieur des
programmes a rendu ses préconisations
pour le programme de l'enseignement
commun et de l'enseignement optionnel de
d'éducation physique et sportive au mois
d'octobre 2010 8 après une consultation
les textes réglementaires concernant les
nouveaux programmes seront présentés aux
instances fin décembre pour une
publication au premier trimestre de
l'année 2019
enfin avec la ministre des sports nous
avons une action volontariste à l'âge de
l'école à l'âge du collège et à l'âge du
lycée pour promouvoir les pratiques
sportives dans le cadre de l'éducation
physique et sportive mais aussi dans le
cadre des associations sportives le
mercredi vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur il y a beaucoup qui est fait
pour l'éducation physique et sportive et
des choses qui ne l'on ne retrouve pas
pour d'autres disciplines
s'agissant des langues et cultures
anciennes il nous a semblé indispensable
pour le 2 pour le rebond que nous
souhaitons que l puissent bénéficier
d'un poids particulier dans le nouveau
baccalauréat c'est un signal que nous
envoyons qui en effet est unique et que
nous assumons ça ne signifie pas à
quelque chose en défaveur des
enseignements optionnels autres comme le
sport les arts ou les langues qui sont
encouragés de bien d'autres façons
mais nous avons voulu envoyer un signal
que nous assumons pour le renouveau du
latin et du grec en france l'évaluation
de l'éducation physique et sportive se
fera dans le cadre du contrôle continu
il y aura une prise en compte aussi des
bulletins qui compteront pour 10 % de la
note finale il ya donc de multiples
élément d'encouragement des pratiques
physiques et sportives que nous
n'imposerons pas à d'autres
encouragements d'autres disciplines je
vous remercie
ce ça va il vous reste quarante et une
secondes pour répondre à monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le ministre si j'ai bien
entendu et je les dis dans mes propos et
un effort va être fait sur le
l'encadrement et la formation du sport
et l'initiation aux sports dans les
programmes et 3 que c'était c'est un
signe très positif mais vous n'avez pas
répondu à la question qui est celui des
options et je pense qu'il est
regrettable aujourd'hui que le sport qui
est déjà très mal traités au niveau
budgétaire
chaque année le budget du sport baisse
que seul le sport aussi soit aussi aussi
maltraité sur le plan éducatif avec un
certain nombre de jeunes et notamment
dans des quartiers qui sont des secteurs
difficiles qui s'engagent par passion
vous aurez au niveau exact sur le sport
et qui se s'est engagement ne sera pas
reconnu à sa juste valeur au moment du
bac c'est regrettable